depuis cet événement les cloches de
l'église de Baulieu les lches ne sonnent
plus et non le 11 décembre dernier un
violent orage s'abat sur cette commune
la foudre frappe le grand clocher de
l'église abasstiale et engendre 40000 €
de dégâts le chauffage et l'éclairage de
l'édifice religieux sont endommagés mais
également son paratonire qui a pourtant
bien joué son rôle pour changer la tête
de ce dispositif et qu'il continue à
protéger son clocher une intervention
inédite était programmée ce mercredi
matin et pour cela il fallait prendre de
la hauteur Sébastien Branger Anthony
Dupuit est un cordiste spécialisé dans
la réfelection des paratonnaire
aujourd'hui il doit grimper en haut du
clocher de l'église abatiale
Saint-Pierre qui culmine à 62 m de haut
une routine pas vraiment car l'ascension
de ce clocher est plutôt technique alors
la particularité de ce clocher c'est
qu'en fait le tout l'intérieur est creux
il n'y a aucune charpente aucun accès à
partir du de l'emplacement connu enfin
la forme conique c'est entièrement creux
c'est un enten noir à l'envers et on ne
peut pas
accéder autrement quand ce qu'on appelle
en artificiel c'est on crée des
amarrages on monte sur l'amarage on en
recrée un au-dessus et donc le la
vitesse de progression c'est bah 70 cm
par 70 cm c'est d'être attaché là percer
là une fois accroché au clocher Anthony
devient le centre d'intérêt des Badeau
présents sur le parvis on a voulu
gardeer ça avec alors les mains dans la
bouche alors avec avec peur pour lui
mais il il il se débrouille très très
bien il me semble le clocher a été
rénové il y a quelques années à peine et
depuis qu'il a été frappé par la foudre
il est sans protection l'intervention
était donc urgente il faut absolument
que le parathonur soit remis si jamais
on a un nouvel éclair un nouvel orage il
faut absolument que le clochier soit
protégé on a mis 4 ans pour le
reconstruire on pas envie de le voir
descendre trop rapidement le paratonire
est aujourd'hui fonctionnel quant à
notre cordiste il sera demain sur un
autre paratonire celui de Notre Dame de
Paris